sur ce plateau robben krakowski et vient
de nous rejoindre vous êtes historien
maître de conférences à l'université de
genève
bonjour vous êtes également l'auteur du
livre populisme en europe centrale et
orientale aux éditions fayard
quel regard est ce que vous portez sur
cette loi dont promulgué hier soir par
android ou d'aller les opposants à cette
loi parle de loi qui musèle les juges
est ce que la liberté est menacée
effectivement cette loi s'inscrit dans
dawn d'une série de mesures que le
gouvernement polonais a adopté depuis
depuis plusieurs années maintenant est
qui qui cherchent à limiter les pouvoirs
de la justice et des médias donc ces
contre-pouvoirs dont le rôle est de
l'enquêté sur sur le pouvoir de l'état
et garantir à tous là la capacité de
s'exprimer dans l'espace public comme si
comme s'il était parfaitement et égaux
et il revient plus là il n'y a pas la
séparation des pouvoirs il ya toujours
la séparation des pouvoirs mais ce que
le gouvernement polonais essaye de
mettre en place c'est de renforcer le
pouvoir de l'état comme défenseur de la
communauté nationale qui seraient en
danger pour toute une série de raisons
qu'on pour qu on pourrait évoquer la
crise démographique à la pologne devrait
perdre à peu près 15 % de la population
d'ici 2050 il y avait des changements
géopolitiques ou l'union européenne des
etats-unis qui a accompagné la
transition dans les années 90 se sont
progressivement retirées de l'europe
centrale et se vide politique a été
investi par d'autres puissances de la
russie la chine avec la ruda soir où la
crise crise de la crimée il y a
également la crise migratoire qui depuis
plusieurs années en fait à accentuer ces
phénomènes de
d'inquiétude et qui ont provoqué ce
qu'on appelle une crise existentielle
c'est-à-dire un sentiment de peur pour
existence de la communauté nationale est
la réponse à cette a7 à ses peurs et de
trouver un acteur qui pourrait défendre
la communauté
c'est à dire l'état et pour cela il faut
renforcer l'europe de l'état et donc
diminuer le pouvoir des juges de système
judiciaire et des médias mais quand on
entend emmanuel macron mettre en garde
les autorités polonaises contre la
négation des principes européens qui ce
monde doit comprendre
on doit comprendre la chose simple c'est
que pour emmanuel macron comme pour
d'autres d'autres acteurs européens
l'union européenne est un bloc c'est un
c'est un bloc de valeurs sur lesquelles
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas transiger
et emmanuel macron à le rappeler lors de
sa visite hier et avant-hier on ne peut
pas à la fois bénéficier des aides
notamment des structurelles européennes
pour améliorer les conditions de vie des
populations locales et de l'autre côté
mener des politiques qui sont à
l'encontre des règles sur lequel à des
acteurs européens se sont mis d'accord
lorsque ça veut dire qu'il va y avoir
des conséquences sur les relations entre
paris et varsovie où surtout qu'entre
bruxelles et varsovie - la commission
européenne a déjà saisi la cour de
justice européenne et a enjoint le
gouvernement polonais à ne pas
adopter ce texte il y aura probablement
d'autres fonctions qui vont qui vont
être adoptés dans l'est dans les jours
qui viennent
en 2010 vite l'union a déclenché l
article 7
même si en pratique il n'ya aucune
mesure concrète qui est qu'ils sont et
suit donc les les relations entre
l'union européenne et la pologne sont
assez tendus sur ce point justement vous
parlez de ce qui s'est passé en 2018
on a l'impression que les les tensions
entre bruxelles et varsovie sont assez
récurrente en impression que c'est un
vieux serpent de mer mais qu'au final
l'union européenne ne sévit pas ou peu
quelles sont ses marges de manoeuvre
ses marges de manoeuvre sont portent
notamment sur les aides structurelles
que l'union européenne apporte aux
régions sous-développées de l'europe
dont une partie se situe en europe
centrale et orientale est donné dans les
balkans y compris pour les pays associés
je rappellerai à peu près 50% du budget
européen est réservé à ces structures
elles donc c'est des sommes extrêmement
extrêmement important et qui depuis
depuis 20 ans ont permis de transformer
la vie quotidienne des populations
or il reste toujours des des points là
négatif il reste des des différends
entre les capitales où les grandes
villes qui sont connectés au monde
globalisé où marc solvi comme comme
prades et des régions si tu sois en la
périphérie de ces de ces pays où le
niveau de vie et plusieurs fois
inférieur à celui des capitales je donne
un exemple en pologne la galicie dans la
région dans le sud est du pays le niveau
de vide dans cette région est cinq fois
inférieur à celui de vagues de varsovie
la capitale
donc il ya des disparités
régional ya des disparités entre les
catégories socioprofessionnelles le
creusement des inégalités depuis les
années 90 avec la montée d'une forme
d'oligarchie qui a profité des années de
transition et les populations lambda qui
ont sur des épaules desquels on a fait
porter en grande partie le poids social
de la transition
il y a il y a également
est-ce que le fait que andré doudin
promulguer cette loi est juste après la
les critiques des manuels macron juste
après le départ d'emmanuel mcnaught de
sa visite en pologne
qu'est-ce qu'il faut il voir à ce que
c'est un pied de nez à l'europe et à la
france
d'une certaine façon c'est un pied de
nez à l'union européenne pour les
leaders du pis le changement de la doua
sont une affaire interne intérieure
avait abandonné et ça ne rentre pour eux
de leurs points de vue ne pas du tout en
porte à faux avec l'adhésion à l'europe
et enfin emmanuel macron de lors de sa
visite à rappeler que au contraire
l'adhésion aux valeurs et aux principes
de solidarité avec des aides constitue
constituant donc donc il peut y avoir un
probablement dans les jours qui viennent
des mesures de rétorsion c'est le mot de
la fin merci al rahman krakowski d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes historien maître de
conférences à l'université de genève et
auteur du populisme en europe centrale
et orientale aux éditions fayard
merci